we begin here this morning with a win of
sorts for the house committee
investigating the january 6th assault on
the u.s capitol former trump white house
adviser steve bannon was found guilty on
friday on two counts of contempt of
congress bannon defied a subpoena for
months to testify before the committee
he is the closest person to former
president trump to be charged with a
crime in connection with the
insurrection
on thursday the committee concluded its
last hearing before the summer recess
and after referencing a steady stream of
new evidence is planning more hearings
in september
christina rofini has more from capitol
hill christina good morning
good morning jeff as you mentioned the
threat of prosecution was really the
only leverage the committee had to
compel steve bannon to testify but
somewhere along the way they made the
calculation he may never cooperate and
they wanted to send a signal to other
possibly reluctant witnesses either
respond to the subpoena or defend
yourself in court
we may have lost a battle here today but
we're not going to lose this war former
trump adviser steve bannon was defiant
after being found guilty on two charges
of contempt of congress his attorney
david showin says the court got it wrong
you will see this case reversed on
appeal bannon was indicted in november
for not complying with a subpoena from
the january 6 congressional committee
claiming executive privilege protected
him from having to cooperate now we have
the january 6th unselect committee of
political acts former president trump
blasted that committee at a rally last
night in arizona if i announced that i
was not going to run any longer for
political office
the persecution of donald trump would
immediately stop this week the january 6
committee held what was supposed to be
its final finale prime time hearing i
don't want to say the elections over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election is over okay
which included outtakes of then
president trump's address to the nation
hours after aides family members and
friends tried to get him to intervene
during the siege of the capitol we have
a clear thought if we move quickly the
committee also played an interview with
a white house security official who said
secret service agents trying to secure
the vice president were fearful for
their own lives there were calls to
say goodbye to family members
over the course of eight public hearings
more than 800 interviews and a year of
investigation the seven democrats and
two republicans argued that trump
willfully decided not to act to protect
the capital what they call a dereliction
of duty the president certainly has
criminal exposure we will stop the steal
now it will be up to the justice
department to decide if it will take the
unprecedented step of bringing charges
against a former american president
no person is above the law in this
country i can't say it any more clearly
than that
now this week was the last scheduled
meeting a hearing committee meeting but
the committee members say that so many
people have been listening to this
testimony more witnesses are coming
forward and now they're going to
schedule more hearings in september dana
all right hollywood couldn't have
scripted this christina thank you